first i want to say this is a terrific
film with incredible performances i am
definitely looking forward to talking to
you about it but i have to ask once you
were ready to make your future debut as
a writer and director
knowing that you'd have to
dedicate all this time to it did you
ever consider lighter fare the first
time around was it always this film and
this story that you felt compelled to
tell
hey that you know it's funny i had no
idea what i was getting into i had no
idea um i was so naive as an actor
i mean i've told this story i at the rap
party
you know as an actor that's it you know
you're done and you go home and you
maybe do some adr and i don't know
occasionally i guess there's re-shoes
but you're basically in and then you get
to go to you know hopefully some
premiere later and celebrate
so i i was i was crying i was so
emotional you know people wanted me to
you know give a toast or speech and i
was so emotional the next day i was
driving around sun valley in the
mountains like
just holding back t i was just a mess
and um
i had accomplished nothing like i'd done
nothing you know what i mean i i i now i
talk to directors and you know they say
oh yeah principal photography is a
vacation you know that's that's that's a
that's a joke that's a vacation that's
fun um everything starts happening in
post and
so i i look it has been a it has been a
lot it's been emotional it was emotional
writing it it was emotional making it
and it's emotional talking about it um
but i had no choice i mean i i i this
thing took over my life i mean i didn't
i didn't start doing the research
because i wanted to make a movie i
started reading about these things
because i was upset you know because i i
felt like i needed to know more and i
was scared and i was frustrated or angry
and i just needed to know
so there was never any question
about having to do this work i just i
did not know how much it entailed um as
you know writer producer director
you know everything i'm i'm the
production company you know i'm just i'm
i'm just overwhelmed but i i you know
it's also it's also sort of a dream come
true you know and and now that audiences
are responding to it i'm just
you know i just feels like i have more
work to do but i could think of nothing
nothing better you know
it seems like there are just there's an
endless list of things that could have
gone wrong with this i mean
you're telling a story that's so
emotional that could have been so
just it could have ended up being
unwatchable just because it would have
been so hard to watch and yet somehow
you are compelled to watch these
people's story
and you're telling
really just a story with conversations
and you're mostly in just one room i
mean all of those things could have gone
bad at every turn
when did you realize it was actually all
working and that it was a compelling
story yeah we
you know i got i got good feedback right
from the script
um i think like i think look
i tried to treat the conversation
i tried to treat these
these as four equal
parties four four equal
human beings real human beings there was
no good or bad there was no antagonist
or protagonist there was a kind of
equivalence you know and a kind of i i
treated them as
i wanted their humanity and i wanted
them to have dignity um and so i think
that was important from the very first
step that i wasn't trying to say this
person's at fault this person did this
thing where these characters are going
to find it out so they can blame them
it's about the complexity of being a
human being and the mistakes we make the
tragic mistakes we make or the things we
miss
because we love
unconditionally you know because
you know we love
our children so much
we make mistakes
and uh that's felt truthful and when i
did this research you know and read
about these things that's what i that's
what i read about you know i didn't i
rarely i ca if any you know
very rarely read about parents that were
monsters you know or parents that you
know you're so conspicuously
bad
that's just not what i've found and so i
think that starting from that point i
think helped the script and i got good
feedback i was i was open i wanted notes
i wanted to change things i you know i
didn't have any experience so i didn't i
don't think i had a big ego about it i
just i just wanted it to be better
um and then when i got the actors
you know i wanted we had a two and a
half day rehearsal
and they we sat at a table to do table
work which was basically dissecting the
script and making sure it all worked so
we were getting a lot of good work done
there because i needed to make sure the
words were there so they could take
these emotional journeys that they would
the words would carry them to these
emotional places because the the four
actors are better actors than i am and i
wasn't about to sit there telling them
how you how you'd be emotional we they
know how to do that it was just about
making sure that the journey was there
but the other thing we were doing is
ryan jackson healing my cinematographer
he was there with a camera we had our
alexa mini and we had lenses we had the
camera we were going to shoot with and
he moved around the table
to sort of help us understand our shot
list in between the rehearsal and the
shoot you know we wanted to it was a
camera test
and
we went back a couple days later you
know when ryan gave me the sent me the
footage and i saw it i saw i saw i saw
the movie you know i could see it you
know we obviously weren't at yet in
idaho but i saw these actors
playing with each other and reading
these lines and i knew i knew i knew it
was going to work you know
did you make a conscious decision from
the beginning not to be in the first
film that you did as a writer and
director i mean did you intentionally
not want to direct yourself or was there
did it just not feel like there was a
role for you
it was never conscious i mean the sense
that you know i i wrote that opening
first i mean i wrote that in one sitting
because i wanted i love this idea of
people helping people and i love the
misdirection
of not knowing where this was going i i
really believe if the movie was just the
four parents
the audience would connect with it
differently that it would be it would it
would be a movie if that makes sense
you'd get to sit down you got to watch
this you'd meet these people it's
fiction and you could be safely
disconnected from it safely detached so
and i worry that you would not be as
empathetic you would not be as affected
you would not be as engaged and
connected to these people and if you
just met them on their own so if i
introduce them through these three
supporting characters that that feel
like they're from another movie that um
there's almost a comedic element there's
sort of you we get to laugh at a few
jokes we kind of lean in wondering what
is this what are we seeing that by the
time the parents arrive the audience can
be blindsided by what's what's what the
movie is really about and i i thought
that that
i know i'm not sure how to explain this
but i just believe that that would
connect us
in a more uh intense way with the story
the the the empathy would be greater
that our connection would be more
profound if we did not see it coming you
know if we we learned about this in this
sort of organic you know kind of um
you know sort of sort of odd kind of
kind of way um uh but yeah no i you know
i i wrote those supporting parts didn't
write you know apart from me and then
the parents you know i i i felt like i
you know i'm not i'm not quite there yet
but i i never
i never thought about it i never
consciously thought about it one way or
the other there just wasn't a part for
me i um
i don't know i don't really at the
moment have any interest in directing
anything that i'm in i i don't know i
don't know for some reason
i feel like i want to just tell a story
that's in my head
and
have a deep emotional connection with it
and at the moment
acting placing myself in a role i feel
like would muddle um what would uh would
be a distraction
in that relationship if that makes sense
yeah no it's just interesting because i
i talk to a lot of actors who direct and
some are totally okay with directing
themselves and others never want to
direct themselves there doesn't really
seem to be a
in between
yeah funny interesting well i mean i
will say i want to i want to make
another movie just simply to see if i
can improve on the mistakes that i made
and just i feel like this is having a
success and i feel like i i need to i
need to do another one just because of
that um uh but i don't know we'll see
we'll see i
yeah it's certainly not like i have no
desire to like go you know play and
direct hamlet you know
no offense to the guys that did
awesome you know i think it's great i'm
a big kenneth branagh fan melody
great
did you always know that you wanted to
take this journey to a place of
redemption and forgiveness or would you
have been okay if it never got to that
point if it didn't feel right well yeah
you know i wanted to believe in those
ideas because i i didn't know if i was
capable of them you know i
the genesis is kind of of the film is
there the literal catalyst was the the
parkland shooting because i was a parent
for that time it was the first sort of
major high-profile
mass shooting that i that i had
with when i had a child and um it
affected me uh so differently and i was
overwhelmed and i started doing this
reading about it um
but when i came across these meetings
the connection i made was with the truth
and reconciliation commission in south
africa which when i learned about that
in college i was deeply disturbed by it
because i did not think i could do it i
did not think i could forgive someone
who took a loved one or a family member
from me i i i i it terrified me because
what that meant is that i would be
living a life of hate and blame
forever you know that i'd be i'd be
stuck with that pain and that resentment
and hatred and it's that's just that's a
terrifying thing to think about and i
had to confront those feelings again
when i when these when this parkland
shooting happened because i was a parent
and i started to worry about my child in
the country she was going to grow up
into
and
i thought about these things again and
so it wasn't um
i wanted to know i didn't know how i was
going to get there necessarily you know
i read a lot about the amnesty hearings
in south africa and there's not there's
not a whole lot to read about these
meetings in in the wake of shootings
here obviously they're private they're
painful they're extremely sensitive it's
not as if you get some transcript
there's little details you get here and
there that you know people have been
open enough to share um
but i tried to sort of construct one but
like i said you know i was coming at it
from having these people all be
inherently good human beings so i didn't
know how we were going to get there but
i i was curious i was i was interested
in the idea that forgiveness doesn't
benefit all the parties equally you know
and maybe there's even a transactional
quality to it that i get to forgive you
and feel better about myself but what
does that what does that mean for you
you know and i i wanted to explore that
because i i just didn't know
i didn't know how any of this stuff
worked but i i felt like i needed to i
felt like i desperately wanted to
believe in reconciliation and
forgiveness but i just didn't know how
to get there so that's i mean that is
what the movie is it's i mean it's very
personal in the sense that i'm i'm
working through this myself
and you know with these four characters
is sort of you know my proxy i just
thought that moment was so interesting i
i have watched the redemption project
which is a show that van jones did where
you know
the victim or their family and
perpetrators sit down across from each
other and have a conversation and those
episodes were so interesting because it
never was you know no one episode turned
out the same way some people
forgave some didn't some thought they
weren't going to and did it just it was
so interesting and this felt
so just natural which i thought was
interesting because i mean obviously you
have a script but
it didn't feel like that was a scripted
moment
yeah yeah no thanks i mean you know it's
interesting there's
you know someone was um
you know i i think of this movie as
being you know very much about
restorative justice and someone said
yeah but there's no the victim and the
perpetrator are gone they can't it's not
restorative justice if they're gone
and i i i don't know i want to push back
on that in the sense that
or or maybe that's taking it too
literally or that's limiting our point
of view i i think it's simply the effort
it's making the effort to forgive making
the effort to heal making the effort to
reconcile you know it's it's it's
those intentions are restorative because
they are not punitive those intentions
are restorative because they are not
retributive
um you're not asking for retribution
you're not asking for punishment so i'm
just sort of being redundant here but
you know you know what i mean
that's
that's what it means to me
um but i'm the those the redemption
project the forgiveness project um the
trc in south africa i mean these are the
things that i immerse myself in these
stories um because
in large part because they they don't
all end the same way i mean they're big
critics of the trc in africa i mean even
desmond tutu sort of you know admits
that some of these people could have
could be re-traumatized by going in and
and having to sort of disclose all of
this
and and and not feeling ultimately that
that
it was healing it was it was made it may
have been worse you know so it's it's
incredibly complicated but it's
look
at the end of the day
you know i am so worried about this
increasingly divided country i'm worried
about the country my daughter's growing
up into i'm obviously worried about
these events and the frequent frequency
of them
but i i
i feel like if there's not some effort
to reconcile if there's not some effort
to sort of restore or repair these kind
of broken relationships
uh i i don't know i i don't have a lot
of hope you know i don't know i don't
know how we survive i don't know i don't
know how we can move forward if we can't
start to make a better effort to sort of
bridge this divide you know it seems
like it's just it's just getting further
and further
um
further and further divided as opposed
to trying to trying to kind of reach
some kind of common ground so the idea
of sitting down at a table in the
physical presence of someone not you
know not online not not through avatars
not you know um
being physically present
and trying to work through your problems
with someone that you are at odds with
or feel blamed towards or hate towards i
can think of nothing more extraordinary
and and
uh
[Music]
necessary you know so so you know that
was the story i wanted to tell and i
wanted to lift up that action elevate
that
as as being important and that's one of
the reasons we don't leave the room
really you know it's just four people at
a table white walls very little
production design the church was a
modest church it doesn't look like some
concert hall you know i i i i just
wanted to i just wanted to focus on that
basic action that these people are
trying to work through their differences
the last thing i want to ask you then is
are you someone who do you have other
scripts written that you're or you know
are you currently working on something
now that you've done this
do you use that outlet as sort of like a
catharsis to get right onto the next
project or how are you figuring out what
you want to do i was trying i'm trying i
i'm i feel like i'm still working on
this i'm i'm
i'm so emotionally attached to this i
mean i'm exhausted um
i feel like a crazy person but i can't i
can't break away from it it's like being
in a relationship like i'm just like not
i'm not ready to move on
um i do have other scripts you know i
was working on something when this all
happened and i just sort of put it aside
so you know i have these unfinished
ideas and you know i've been dreaming
about doing this most of my life so i
have a lot of these unfinished ideas
you know that that never sort of made it
that i couldn't i couldn't really get
over that hump this one i was able to i
think mostly because of this this kind
of desperation and urgency i felt around
it i mean i felt like this is a story
it felt important it felt like what
these people are doing is extraordinary
but it shouldn't be extraordinary we
should we should be encouraging it it
should be something that we see happen
more in our society um i wonder i wonder
i wonder if it would be helpful to sort
of
you know make a practice of this you
know um
so you know it it it i i have some i
have another idea but i i truly i think
i need to really be done with this one
first whatever whatever that means
i mean again it just it feels like a lot
of directors either have to jump right
into something else or they need time
and distance i never want to work again
i
literally never want to work again
oh yeah that's how i feel right now
yeah i mean i can't imagine the
emotional rollercoaster and journey you
must have been on with this i mean
clearly it's something to be proud of
and it must be rewarding to do but
i would imagine it's still
a
definite emotional journey it's a lot it
is it's a it's emotional i need a i
definitely need a break i want to be a
dad and like a just i just want to
i just want to i want those moments you
know what i mean and and
yeah so i so i uh we'll see you know i
um i definitely have ideas but i'm gonna
need a beat you know i'm gonna i'm gonna
need a spa you know or a uh rehab or you
know a mental you know institution or
something one of those some well
something will work something will get
me energized again